100% des humains sont concernés par les
changements climatiques
ça nous impacte tous impacte notre
travail notre santé notre alimentation
notre patrimoine mais individuellement
c'est un aussi évident par exemple
seulement 7% de la consommation d'eau
provient des ménages 100% 7%
vous sentez l'impuissance là c'est assez
décourageant
moi je suis d'autant plus découragés que
la plupart des discours qu'on entend
sont ses vrais inquiétant démoralisant
voire même parfois terrifiant mais pour
moi l'écologie c'est pas qu'un discours
électoral c'est très important de sortir
l'écologie de ses incarnations on va pas
parler de partis politiques on va parler
de nous parce qu'on se demande souvent
qu'est ce que je peux faire moi
l'écologie c'est un acte quotidien
c'est à la fois tout petits est très
grand et puis souvent c'est surtout du
bon sens on en a tous marre de recevoir
des dizaines de prospectus qu'on ne lit
pas si vous coller un sticker stop pub
sur votre boîte aux lettres vous avez
évité environ 80% des 31 kg de papier
que reçoit chaque année un foyer
français
alors attention c'est pas parce que on
ferme le robinet quand on se lave les
dents qu'on a sauvé la planète
il n'y a pas de geste magique c'est là
qu'est tout le problème c'est difficile
pour tout le monde
on est tous paresseux on est tous pas
très bon on est tous plombés par ses
automatismes qui finissent par former
notre identité et puis on n'est pas tous
au même niveau mais on a une
responsabilité
alors il faut créer des étapes
par exemple si vous affichez le
calendrier des fruits et légumes de
saison dans votre cuisine
vous pouvez vous rappeler d'une idée
révolutionnaire il y à des saisons tous
les légumes ne poussent pas en même
temps
en hiver il n'y a pas de tomates c'est
comme ça vous pouvez aussi vous l'avez
avec un pain de savon
j'ai connu plus révolutionnaire et
pourtant ma vous éviter de produire du
plastique et puis vous évitez d'utiliser
des produits chimiques qui vont polluer
l'eau un autre palier ce serait de
changer de fournisseur d'électricité
ça a l'air très compliqué ça prend cinq
minutes
vous avez la même qualité et la même
électricité mais vous vous avez la
garantie que votre consommation elle
contribue à développer les énergies
renouvelables
vous pourriez aussi commencé à modérer
votre consommation de viande pas
forcément devenir végétarien demain mais
vous engager dans un processus
ces étapes je les ai franchi c'était pas
facile
j'adore la viande vraiment j'adore la
viande
je fais partie des gens qui pensent qu
une côte de boeuf c'est peut-être ce
qu'il ya de meilleur
mais j'ai réussi parce que ça m'a paru
nécessaire et que j ai pris du plaisir
ça a été une réaction en chaîne autour
de moi il ya plein de gens qui me disent
est ce que ça aura vraiment un impact et
ou bien qu'il se dise
j'y arriverai jamais c'est important de
prendre en compte notre médiocrité à
tous là dessus et de prendre le temps de
se donner les moyens de se dire tous
ensemble
on va y arriver aujourd'hui il ya des
coachs pour faire du sport il ya des
coachs pour arrêter de fumer
moi j'ai créé un coach pour devenir
écolo un assistant personnel pour créer
sa propre écologie ça s'appelle 90 jours
c'est une appli mobile gratuite qui vous
accompagne pour changer concrètement
votre quotidien
ça commence par un questionnaire qui
permet de définir votre profil vous
proposer un premier pas celui que vous
avez le plus de chances de réussir
ça peut être tout petit c'est pas parce
que il est déjà très tard c'est pas
parce qu'on sait tous qu'il ya une
urgence qu'on n'a pas le droit de
commencer tout petit on peut pas se
contenter de créer de la contrainte et
de la souffrance parce que ça doit
rentrer dans notre quotidien ça doit
devenir automatique
un défi à la fois et pour ça c'est des
filles on va les expliquer avec un court
texte qui précise pourquoi ce défi est
important
et quel va être son impact
environnemental on va aussi vous
accompagner en vous donnant des liens
des conseils des bonnes pratiques pour
être sûr que vous réussissiez pour
passer d'une écologie de la privation à
une écologie qui crée de nouvelles
pratiques et enfin le plus important va
vous permettre de le partager
parce que l'écologie doit apprendre à
dire bravo et vous allez être fier de
réussir à changer si vous n'y arrivez
pas il ya un panic button
vous appuyez dessus c'est moi qui
réponds au téléphone il faut croire que
tout le monde s'en sort bien parce que
sur quinze mille utilisateurs
j'ai reçu qu'un seul coup de fil ça
marche
la force de l'écologie c'est quand on
multiplie par 365 est tous ensemble
les utilisateurs de l'application ils
ont déjà réussi à économiser chaque
année 900 mille kilos de co2 et un
million de lits
rdo et ça continue ça c'est très
impressionnant c'est très impressionnant
mais c'est pas mon seul objectif
90 jours c'est un moyen c'est pas une
fin c'est un gps ça vous montre le
chemin
plutôt que de vous donner simplement la
destination en fait on a imaginé le
meilleur début possible la meilleure
manière de commencer la plus simple la
plus accessible
moi je suis designer de formation le
design en fait c'est intégrer des
contraintes dans un système pour le
faire bien fonctionner et je me suis
rendu compte que l'écologie c'est du
design parce que c'est intégrer les
limites de notre monde de notre planète
dans notre mode de vie pour vivre mieux
notre mise à jour
elle est nécessaire quand le contexte
évolue quand les technologies évoluent
on fait une mise à jour pour que le
système fonctionne mieux notre contexte
a évolué on peut plus permettre de vivre
exactement comme avant on doit améliorer
le système
on est tous les designers de notre
quotidien
vous êtes tous les designers de votre
transition
j'aurais qu'une seule question ce sera
quoi votre premier défi merci